[موسيقى]
شهد حي الميدان بالعاصمه السوريه دمشق
الجمعه انفجارا اودى بالعشرات بين قتيل
وجريح المصادر الرسميه قالت انه ناجم عن
عمل ارهابي نفذه انتحاري بينما اتهمت
المعرضه النظام السوري نفسه بتدبير هذا
الانفجار ياتي الحادث بعد اسبوعين من هجوم
مماثل وقع في دمشق ايضا مع بدايه عمل
المراقبين العرب وقبل يومين من اجتماع
اللجنه العربيه المعنيه بالملف السوري
التي ستناقش اول تقرير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منهم نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين امنيا ماذا يعني ان تشهد العاصمه
السوريه وقوع مثل هذه الهجمات مرتين خلال
اسبوعين سيا سيا اي رسائل اراد المسؤولون
عن هذا الانفجار ايصالها للاطراف الاخرى
المعنيه
بالازمه السلام عليكم لم تتمكن كثير من
التحليلات السياسيه من الخروج من دائره
الربط بين التفجيرات التي شهدتها دمشق
وزياره وفد المراقبين العرب فمع بدايه
مهمتهم وقع تفجيران بالقرب من مقرات امنيه
ومع اقتراب مناقشه تقريرهم الاول يقع
تفجير في حي الميدان احد اكثر الاحياء
خروجا للتظاهر ضد النظام الحدثان وقع يوم
جمعه وهو الموعد الاسبوعي للتظاهرات
الممتده على مدى عشره
اشهر عشر دقائق عقب وقوع التفجير وكان كل
شيء واضحا بالنسبه للنظام السوري الهجوم
ارهابي استهدف حيا شعبيا مكتظا بالسكان
بغرض ايقاع اكبر قدر من الضحايا اما منفذه
فهو انتحاري اختار حي الميدان في دمشق
فاوقع على الفور عشرات القتلى والجرحى
روايه تحيل المسؤوليه الى جهات عديده تبدا
بالقاعده ولا تنتهي بنشط المعارضه بما
فيهم الجيش السوري الحر الذي نفى كما بقيه
فصائل المعارضه الاخرى ضلوعه في التفجير
بل واتهم النظام بتدبيره لصرف الانظار عن
جرائمه اتهام تسنده حسب المعارضين حجج
عديده اولها طبيعه حي الميدان الذي عرف
اكثر من سواه بكونه الانشطه بين احياء
العاصمه في معارضه النظام والانخراط في
الثوره الشعبيه التي تهزه منذ نحو عشره
اشهر وقد نال الحي نتيجه هذا الموقف نصيبه
الوافر من الضحايا قتل وجرحى ومعتقلين
فكيف يعقل بنظر المشككين في الروايه
الرسميه ان يستهدف اعداء النظام اكثر
احياء العاصمه مناهضه له وفي ذات الاتجاه
يتساءل المعارضون عن سر توقيت الانفجار
الذي يسبق بيومين فقط اجتماعا للجنه
الوزاريه العربيه يفترض ان ينظر في تقرير
اولي لبعثه المراقبين العرب وهو ما يذكر
بتفجيري الثال والشر من الشهر الماضي
الذين ارتبطا ايضا بالمراقبين العرب من
حيث انهما وقعا في اول يوم لوصول طلائع
الى دمشق وبعيدا عن الاستنتاجات لفت
المشككون في روايه النظام للتفجير الى
لقطات تثبت ما وصفوه بالتوظيف الاعلامي
المضلل للحدث مشيرين في هذا للقطات مرت
حتى من خلال اجهزه الاعلام الرسميه في
سياق ما سموه محاولات النظام المتعجل
لتوظيف التفجير في شيطنه خصومه هنا مثلا
يحمل احدهم شعار التلفزيون الرسمي وهو
يحاول ترتيب المسرح تمهيدا لابراز على غير
واقعه وهنا اثنان من رجال الشرطه يمثلان
مشهد المصاب ومنقذه امام كاميرات قناه
الاخباريه الرسميه ثم ينهض بعد انتهاء
المشهد وهكذا تقول المعارضه ان النظام هو
من كان بحاجه الى التفجير الذي جاء كما
سابقه ايضا في يوم جمعه خصصها المتظاهرون
هذه المره لطلب الحمايه من المجتمع الدولي
ذات الجهه التي تقول المعارضه ان النظام
يحاول استدرار عطفها بافتعال مثل هذه
التفجيرات
معنا في هذه الحلقه من القاهره الدكتور
وليد البني عضو الامانه العامه ومدير مكتب
العلاقات الخارجيه بالمجلس الوطني السوري
ومن بيروت السياسي والاعلامي اللبناني
محمد عبيد اهلا
بضيفي لو بدانا ببيروت ومحمد
عبيد امنيا سيد عبيد كيف تفهم ما جرى في
دمشق لا شك ان المخطط لهذا العمل الارهابي
ذكي الى درجه انه يحاول ان يلبس النظام
هذه او هذا التفجير او هذه الجريمه
النكراء عبر
يعني القيام بها في منطقه شهدت بعض
التظاهرات منها سلميه ومنها
محاولات امنيه سابقه ضد رجال النظام وضد
القوى الامنيه وضد القوى العسكريه التي
كانت تحاول ان تضبط الوضع في المرحله
السابقه مع العلم ان كل الاحتجاجات في تلك
المنطقه خفت اكثر من مره الى درجه انني
انا شخصيا الاسبوع الماضي كنت في دمشق
وزرت هذه المنطقه وبالتالي اعرفها جيدا
واعرف ان يعني
الاحتجاجات باتت في نهاياتها ولا تعدو
كونها بعض التجمعات الصغيره كل يوم جمعه
بعد الخروج من الشارع وتحديدا يوم الخميس
الماضي خرج في هذا الحي حوالي 100 متظاهر
معارض وخرج في مقابلهم اكثر من 2000 مؤيد
للنظام وغير مؤيد يعني من الجماعات التي
التي تسعى الى الاصلاح ومنهم بعض المثقفين
والوجوه الوطنيه الداخليه التي تح التي
تسعى الى الاصلاح انما تعتمد الاسلوب
السلبي في السلمي عفوا في هذه العمليه اي
ما حصل اليوم اعتقد انه محاوله لتوريط
النظام ول افهام العالم ان وتحديدا ونحن
على ابواب اجتماع الاول للجنه العربيه
لمناقشه تقرير بعثه المراقبين الذي يبدو
ان ليس الكثير من يعني بدءا من الو
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وصولا الى
فرنسا الى بعض الدول العربيه حتى امين عام
الجامعه العربيه لا يرضى عن عمل هذه
البعثه سنتحدث عن هذا يعني لا اسمح لي فقط
لانه الجانب السياسي سيكون بعد الفاصل
نريد ان نبقى في الزاويه الامنيه
الان دكتور وليد البني امنيا كيف
فهمتم ما جرى في دمشق من
تفجير ما
فهمناه هو ان النظام يريد ان يقول لاهالي
دمشق لاهالي اهم منطقتين تخرج للتظاهر في
دمشق كفرسوسه والميدان بانه اذا اذا ما
بداتم بالخروج لاحتلال الساحات كما كان
منويا من قبل السوريين في دمشق والمناطق
الاخرى فاننا لن نضع لكم قناصه وانما
سنفجر كما فعل اليوم في الميدان ومنذ
اسبوعين في كفر سوسر انا اعتقد بان ما جرى
هو من افعال النظام ونحن كلنا نعلم بان
النظام والقاعده متداخلان كما شرح مره
وكما نشر في ويكيليكس رئيس الاستخبارات
السوريه علي مملوك لنائب وزيره الخارجيه
الامريكيه لشؤون الامن بان المخابرات
السوريه تبني نفسها داخل القاعده وبالتالي
فان فقط واحد له مصلحه بما يجري هو النظام
وليس لكي يري الاخرين او يري العرب او
اللجنه العربيه او ما الى ذلك فقط لكي
يرهب السوريين حتى لا يتجر ويذهبوا
لاحتلال الساحات في دمشق ولكن اسمح لي
يعني اسمح لي اذا كان اسمح لي اذا كان
الهدف هو ارهاب السوريين يفترض على امتداد
هذه الاشهر السابقه هذا هو ما يحصل يوميا
يعني لا الان لاحظنا منذ بدء اللجنه
العربيه مهمتها راينا تفجيرين ما قبل بدء
اللجنه العربيه مهمتها عندما كان النظام
يقتل دو بدون ان يكون هناك اي رقيب لم يكن
مضطرا لفعل ذلك وانما منذ ان بدات اللجنه
العربيه مهمتها بدا يقول النظام بان هذه
المره سيكون القتل جماعيا
وبالعشرة ان لا يخرجوا لكي يتظاهروا
ويحتلوا الساحات لا احد يستطيع ان يعتقد
بان القاعده هي تقوم بخدمه النظام بهذه
الطريقه يعني القاعده تقوم بوضع تفجير في
الميدان قرب جامع الحسن في اكثر منطقه في
دمشق تحدث فيها مظاهرات معاديه للنظام وفي
كفر سوس ايضا بالقرب من جامع الرفاعي وهم
ادعوا بانها مقرات امنيه طبعا في في كل
دمشق المقرات الامنيه تنتشر كالفطر لا
يوجد حي لا يوجد فيه مقر امني لذلك فكره
ان الانفجارات تستهدف المقرات الامنيه
فكره باليه واعتقد ان من يقوم بذلك هو ليس
علىى درجه من الذكاء بحيث يريد ان يورط من
النظام والى درجه من الغباء بحيث يستهين
بعقول الاخرين اسمح لي هل هل نحن وهنا
انتقل الى السيد محمد عبيد هل نحن امام
اتهامين متسرع بمعنى السلطه سارعت الى
اتهام القاعده او اطراف متطرفه كما تسميها
بينما المعارضه سارعت الى اتهام النظام
بذلك
انا في الواقع اعتقد انه لا يمكن لاي نظام
في العالم ان يضرب منطقه من المفترض انها
تشكل له معقلا سياسيا وامنيا واقتصاديا
اي يعني يبرز يبرز من خلال هذا المعقل او
من خلال هذا الموقع انه ممسك بالامور على
الارض على المستوى الامني وعلى المستوى
السياسي وعلى المستوى العسكري انا اعتقد
ان الحاله المتطرفه الاسلاميه الاصوليه
التي تضرب تحاول ان تفهم العالم ان من
يمسك بالواقع على الارض هي ليست ليس ما
يسمى المجلس الوطني السوري اولا وليس
التنسيقيات التي تعمل في الخارج والتي من
المؤسف انه تغطي هذه الاعمال من خلال
وقوفها او من خلال اتهام النظام مباشره
دون البحث فعلا عن من قام بهذه التفجيرات
اولا وثانيا من خلال الترويج الاعلامي
المؤيد عمليا يعني الذي في النهايه يصل
الى نتيجه انه يؤيد هذه التفجيرات لانه
يقول ان النظام مسؤول عنها وعلى النظام ان
يرحل كي تتوقف هذه التفجيرات ولكن ولكن
سيد عبيد ولكن سيد عبيد فقط مداخله سريعه
ا الا يبدو غريبا بان النظام السوري معروف
بانه نظام امني صلب وعلى امتداد سنوات لم
تحصل خروقات كبيره جدا كيف يمكن لمجموعه
في ظل هذه الاوضاع المستنفر اصلا ان تدخل
وتعد وتنفذ والنظام كما يسمى وهو نظام
بوليسي لا يمكن ان ان يتفطن
لذلك وهذا سبب اخر هذا سبب اخر كي اؤكد
فكرتي حول هذا الموضوع بان النظام ليس له
ايه مصلحه ابدا في اظهار الامور على انه
ضعيف او على انه غير ممسك بالواقع الامني
والعسكري خصوصا ان الاطراف التي تسمي
نفسها معارضه في الداخل ذهبت في المواجهه
الى الملعب التي يعتبر فيها النظام اقوى
وهي الملعب الامني والعسكري لذلك اقول ان
من قام بهذه العمليات يحاول ان يرسل رساله
بانه يجب استعجال التدخل الدولي باعتبار
ان بعثه المراقبين لم تصل الى نتيجه على
مستوى ما يسمونه ضبط العنف وبالتالي ال
ضبط الاوضاع الداخليه الامنيه والعسكريه
نعم موضوع موضوع الرسائل بالطبع سنعود
لتفكيكها بعد الفاصل ولكن السيد وليد
البني ما رايك في هذه الحجه انه يفترض ان
النظام يريد ان يظهر بانه ممسك وبان
الازمه في نهاياتها كيف يمكن ان يقدم على
عمل مثل هذا سيشوه ربما اكثر مما يشوه
غيره الكلام على الازمه في على ان الازمه
في نهاياتها كنا نسمعه بعد بعد بعد شهر
واحد من بدء الثوره السوريه بعد بدء شهر
واحد السيد عبيد نفسه قال بانها خلصت وان
الاحتجاجات في اواخرها وان النظام يسيطر
على البلد وما الى ذلك من الواضح بان
السوريين خرجوا للاحتجاج والتظاهر من اجل
استعاده حريتهم وه وهم لن يعودوا الا بها
وبالتالي النظام الان فقد عقله وبدا يتصرف
بشكل هستيري عن طريق القتل الجماعي للناس
عبر التفجيرات
من اجل اخافتهم ومنعهم من التظاهر
ولكن ليس معنيا بان يقال عنه انه
ممسك اسمح لي سيد بني كيف له يعني كيف له
ان يفعل ذلك وهو يعلم ان هناك مراقبين
هناك وقد تنكشف هذه الالعيب بين
قوسين لذلك نحن كمعارض نطلب احاله هذه
الجرائم الى لجنه تحقيق مستقله حتى نرى من
هم الذين قتلوا في داخل السيارات نحن نعلم
تماما ان في الانفج ال جارين الاولين بعض
القتلى الذ الذين اعلن عنهم كان كانوا قد
اعلنوا عنهم سابقا في حوادث اخرى ويقال
وهذا ليس اكيدا طبعا ولكن النظام يفعلها
ويفعل اكثر منها بانه ياخذ بعض المعتقلين
او بعض الاشخاص الذين قتلوا تحت التعذيب
ليضعهم في تلك السيارات ويفجر هذا ليس
بعيدا عن نظام قتل اقرب الناس اليه من اجل
ان يوحي بان هناك مؤامره وما الى ذلك
جرائمه في جرائمه في لبنان معروفه حيث كان
يقتل معارض ض سوريا ويتهم اسرائيل بانها
تقتلهم كما كلنا يعرف وكان الاخ عبيد ومن
ومن لف لفه يخرجون ليدافعوا عن النظام وعن
جرائمه كما هي العاده انا اقول بصراحه
بصراحه سيد بصراحه سيد بني من الصعب من
الصعب جدا في هذه القضيه تحديدا فصل
الامني عن السياسي ولكن مع ذلك سنحاول بعد
الفاصل التطرق الى الجوانب السياسيه او
الرسائل السياسيه كما وصفها السييد عبيد
بعد فاصل لنا عوده لقراءه الرسا سائل
السياسيه من وراء هذا التفجير الذي حدث
الجمعه في دمشق لن عوده بعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قليل اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها قراءه سياسيه
وامنيه لحادث التفجير الذي شهدته دمشق
الجمعه سيد محمد عبيد في في بيروت اذا
سلمنا بما تفضلت بذكره قبل قليل من ان
القاعده او على الاقل عناصر متطرفه كما
توصف هي التي تقف وراء هذا التفجير هنا
اسال ما مصلحه ايه هذه التنظيمات المتطرفه
ان وجدت في القيام بشيء مماثل في دمشق وهي
تعلم بان اصلا هناك حراك بين معارضه وبين
سلطه ولا مكان لها اصلا في هذا المشهد
المضطرب ولا ولا فائده يمكن ان تجنيها
عمليا يعني
اولا اسمح لي ان اعلق قليلا لاني لا اريد
ان يذهب السجال الى سجال شخصي يبدو ان
الدكتور وليد يعني مخطئ لا يعرفني ولا
يعرف جيدا مواقفي وادواره ولا يعرف انني
لم اقل يوما انه بعد شهر انتهت الازمه ليس
لسبب انما لمعرفتي وطلاع على بعض المعطيات
والتقارير والمعلومات الدوليه حول حجم
الهجمه الدوليه الامريكيه والاسرائيليه
والاوروبيه والعربيه على سوريا لذلك لم
اقل يوما ان الازمه ستنتهي غدا ثانيا بما
يعني لبنان هذا امر اخر ارجو ان لا ندخل
به لانه لدي من التفاصيل ما يربك الدكتور
وليد وغيره حول موضوع الجهات التي كانت
تقتل في لبنان او حول بعض الشخصيات
السوريه التي كانت تمسك بالملف اللبناني
والتي هي اليوم حليفه لما يسمى المجلس
الوطني الحاله المتطرفه
ثالثا يتحدث الان عن لجنه تحقيق يبدو انهم
عبر بعثه المراقبين العرب لم يوفقوا
بامثال فيس جيرالد او ديتليف ميلس او
دانييل بلمار كي يورط سوريا والنظام
السوري والرئيس الدكتور بشار الاسد بعد ما
حاولوا توريط سوريا سابقا ورئيسها وبعض
القيادات فيها بموضوع اغتيال المرحوم
الرئيس رفيق الحريري لم يوفقوا عبر بعثه
الم فالان يبحثون عن لجنه تحقيق دوليه او
عبر تطعيم بعثه المراقبين العرب ببعض
الوجوه
الدوليه المشكله اليوم تحولت الى امر اخر
هذه الحاله المتطرفه الاسلاميه التي تمسك
بالارض والتي لا دوره لا للمجلس الوطني
ولا لاي جهه اخرى تسمي نفسها معارضه في
سوريا والتي لم نطلع منها حتى اليوم على
اي برنامج سياسي اصلاحي وحتى تغييري
بوسائل ديمقراطيه سو تبري ير التدخل
العربي والتدخل الدولي هذه الحاله
المتطرفه اليوم هي التي تدير اللعبه على
الارض
وهي مواجه
للنظام اسمح لي ما رايك فيما قالته حركه
الاخوان المسلمين
المعارضه في سياق اتهامها للنظام تقول بان
النظام واجهزته وعصاباته وشبيحته على حد
تعبيرها هم وحدهم المستفيدون من هذا
التفجير هم وحدهم المالكون لادوات هم
وحدهم القادرون عليه هل من محاوله للرد
على هذه الثلاثيه كما كما جاءت يا يا
استاذ العزيز اولا النظام والقياده
السوريه وكل اجهزه الدوله تتبجح يوميا بان
العاصمه دمشق وان حلب وان اللاذقيه وان كل
هذه المدن السوريه العزيزه علينا تعيش
حاله استقرار وان كل كل
هذه المدن تشهد يوميا وعلى راسها العاصمه
تشهد يوميا تظاهرات هائله بمئات الالاف
وبالملائكة
متفرغ لمواجهه تلك العصابات وتلك الحاله
المتطرفه في مناطق اخرى مثل
محيط مدينه حمص ومثل بعض محيط كما ايضا
مدينه ادلب او يعني في محافظه ادلب وفي
جبل الزاويه وفي بعض المناطق الاخرى
التيال نعم فعلا سؤال وجيه انقله للدكتور
وليد البني
تفضل اولا دمشق لم تكن هادئه يوما معروفه
المظاهرات الموجوده في الميدان وكفر سوسه
المنطقتين التي استهدفه التفجير قبل
اسبوعين واليوم الكل يعلم ماذا يحدث في
القابون وفي برزا و وفي نهر عيشا والقدم
وكل هذه الاحياء في دمشق يخرج فيها كل
اسبوع عشرات الالاف هناك عشرات بل مئات
الشهداء سقطوا في دمشق بريفها لذلك لا
يمكننا الادعاء بان دمشق صامته ولم تتحرك
بالتظاهر لا هي ولا اللاذقيه اللاذقيه جعت
بشده وهي الان شبه محتله من قبل اجهزه
النظام و وبالرغم من ذلك كل اسبوع تخرج
المظاهرات في اللاذقيه وفي دمشق وقد بدات
تظهر تخرج المظاهرات في حلب منذ شهر والى
الان ثانيا طالما يقول السيد عبيد بان
هناك الكثير من المظاهرات المؤيده في دمشق
وان دمشق مسيطر عليها من قبل مؤيدي النظام
يستطيع هؤلاء الارهابيون وهم ليسوا الا
ارهابيين نظام ان يفجروا السيارات المفخخه
في الميدان في القرب من المساجد التي تخرج
منها المظاهرات المعاديه للنظام
والمحتل نسمع بتفجير واحد او قتيل واحد او
قناص واحد اعتدى على المظاهرات التي يتبجح
بها النظام بانها تخرج لتاييد هل هذه
العصابات التي تقوم بذلك تريد ان تقتل فقط
معارضي النظام بينما تترك مؤيديه يسرحون
ويمرحون كما يشاؤون وطبعا لا هؤلاء ليسوا
مؤيدي النظام هؤلاء عباره عن عناصر الامن
وبعض وبعض من يرسلهم ا الاخوه في لبنان من
من من لف لف السيد عبيد وامثاله لكي
يتظاهروا في دمشق ويدعمون النظام ثالثا
انا لا استطيع ان افهم لماذا يستهين السيد
عبيد بدماء السوريين حقيقه نعم هو قال
انها انتهت منذ ثلاثه اشهر وعليه ان يتذكر
مره اخرى عليه ان يهتم بشانه افضل لا ياتي
ان ويدافع عن نظام يقتل شعبه بهذه
الطريقه يعني حتى لا حتى لا نحول السجال
الى سجال شخصي فعلا مثل ما قال السيد عبي
عيد سؤال اخير لكلا الضيفين في الدقائق
المتبقيه في النهايه برايك سيد عبيد من هو
اكبر مستفيد مما
حصل اكبر مستفيد مما حصل هو من يسعى الى
اطاله امد الازمه السوريه الداخليه
والخروج بها عن سياقها في اتجاه الاصلاح
والتغيير في بنيه النظام لصالح التطوير
والتحسين وفق وفق عفوا وفق وفق الرؤيه
التي وضعها الرئيس الدكتور بشار الاسد
وهذا الامر لننتظر حتى الاحد المقبل وقبل
الاحد يوم السبت المقبل عندما يجتمع
فيلتمان برئيس وزراء قطر وبام عام الجامعه
العربيه وببعض الوزراء العرب كي نرى ما هي
التعليمات الجديده التي حملها جفري
فيلتمان الى الجامعه العربيه والى بعض
الارك كانان الجامعه العربيه لاستكمال
عمليه النيل من سوريا في المرحله المقبله
باساليب جديده ولا استغرب ان يكون احد هذا
هذه الاساليب ما تفضل به الدكتور وليد حول
لجنه تحقيق دوليه تبدا بفيد جيرالد وننتهي
بما شهدناه في لبنان على مستوى المحكمه
الدوليه نعم سيد البني برايك من هو اكبر
مستفيد بالتاكيد النظام كان يظن نفسه انه
سيكون لمستفيد الاكبر عبر الايحاء بانه
مظلوم ويتعرض الى هجمات ارهابيه من
ارهابيين متطرفين وقاعده بالرغم من ان
جميعنا يعلم ان صديق القاعده الاول الذي
كان يرسلهم سواء الى لبنان او الى العراق
او كل كلك التفجيرات كلنا يتذكر ابو
القعقاع وما فعله من معسكرات للقاعده في
سوريا وارسالها لكي تقوم لتفجيرات في
العراق بالتاكيد النظام يعتقد نفسه
المستفيد الاول ولكن كما قال السيد عبيد
في البدايه بان ان من قام بها هو ذكي جدا
يريد ان ان ان يفجر اعداء النظام حتى يتهم
النظام هذا هو الاسلوب البعثي في العمل
الذي تعودنا عليه في سوريا وهذا هو
الاسلوب الذي طالما عاهده النظام منذ
وجوده وحتى الان سواء في لبنان او في
سوريا شكرا جزيلا لك عضو الامان العامه
ومدير مكتب العلاقات الخارجيه بالمجلس
الوطني السوري الدكتور وليد البني شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من بيروت السياسي والاعلامي
اللبناني محمد عبيد و بهذا نكون قد وصلنا
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء